when people envision the future in art
most often it's seen through a white
lens only eight percent of the 100 top
grossing sci-fi and fantasy films
featured a protagonist of color
half the time the protagonist was will
smith
but we're not all white or will smith
the future looks different
if you look at it through the lens of
black experiences that's why we have
this thing
called afrofuturism the term was coined
by culture critic mark dairy in 1994
to point out the lack of black writers
and black stories and science fiction
but this kind of art existed long before
the term afrofuturism did
just look at music jazz musician sun ra
is probably one of the most recognizable
he lays out now for futuristic design
and his 1973 album space is the place
which you're listening to now and also
became a film
the key is that his future was
afrocentric linking his future self to
ancient forebears in egypt
these ideas were more politically direct
and a lot more funky in george clinton's
parliament during 1975.
we have returned a mothership connection
he connects the struggle of civil rights
and we shall overcome to a positive
future
for i am here he not only references an
old song from the underground railroad
to escape slavery
but he slipped the dust for history into
a positive futuristic ride on his
spaceship as evidence the struggle is
over and we've won
so of course everybody wants to get on
and people did get on
or at least some 90s hip-hop
heavyweights did but afrofuturism also
critiques the way the future looks today
like andre 3000 did on his a.t
to get the future they want not the one
society created for them because of race
and that's why he takes pride in the
difference
of blackness when i practice without
preaching and empowers black
the thing about people it's rooted in
black people
having a better future for ourselves on
our terms
like janelle monae does in queens
this is a common thread of afrofuturism
to overcome the current way society
remains unequal
there needs to be futures where those
problems are solved
afrofuturism shows us what that looks
like it looks like hope
will you be electric electric ladies
will you sleep
or will you preach
you